here with reaction fox news contributor
house speaker newt gingrich
you know it frustrates me everybody we
already paid
top marginal rate of 40 in taxes right
the bottom 50 percent
pay nothing in in income taxes and
now you're going to have an added wealth
tax capital gains tax
uh you're going to add to that corporate
taxes which we will end up paying for
and energy prices now going through the
roof every american's paying
going to be paying through the nose
well i look i think you have to start
with the idea that the democratic
machine
has to have money it's like a great
white shark
if you don't feed it it falls apart if
you don't feed the teachers union
you don't feed the government employees
in illinois
just go down the list so they've got to
get the money from somewhere
they're going to borrow as much as they
can and then they're going to come after
every
hard-working american every american
business
large and small they're going to use
really nice sounding rhetoric
but the truth is they want to put their
hand
in your wallet to take out your money to
give to their allies
and that's the number one reality of
this machine
then you couple in okay all those
high-paying career energy sector jobs
they're wiped away
border control uh construction jobs
they're gone now you're going to
legalize 11 million 15 million
people in this country they'll be
competing for jobs in the middle of a
pandemic
when you're down 17 million jobs at the
top
how do you get high paying jobs in that
environment
well you don't i mean look people who
want to understand what's coming
should look at argentina under juan
peron
they should look at what's happening in
venezuela
they should look at the disaster that we
had in zimbabwe
when you bring in a power structure
focused on ripping off
everybody else to pay off its allies
this isn't about socialism this is
purely about corruption
they need the money uh and you can tell
how bad it is
because the huge amount of money you
mentioned that's going to california
is barely enough to cover up the 34
billion plus
that was lost to fraud i mean the
bureaucracies are now
so incompetent so unwilling to work
so incapable of modernization in
california
they were sending out notices with the
social security numbers on them so
criminals were picking up these things
at the and looking at it
and they were filing false application
one house
got 1700 checks and then this is
everybody who works hard who's honest
who wants to
have a better future for their family
needs to understand
that the corrupt democratic machine has
to rip
you off because it can't control the
very bureaucrats
and the very unions and the very
machines that are the heart of its
existence
so now we got a hundred thousand in one
month illegal immigrants a lot of them
children
okay we got rid of catch and release we
stopped construction of the
of the border wall we got rid of the
stay in mexico policy
okay so for if it's a hundred thousand
and this is not the peak
season for illegal immigrants we expect
a lot more now
we're going to pay for housing we're
going to pay for health care we're going
to pay for education
food shelter is there anything we're not
going to pay for
look i'm i'm a historian by trade and
i've looked at this for years and years
let's be honest if you excuse me if you
stand under a waterfall
you're going to get wet so what biden
has decided to do
is put all of america under a waterfall
of immigration
pretend that it's okay and have
thousands and thousands of people come
in who have coveted
have others come in who have no means of
inconverting an income
have others come in who have health
problems and then he's going to say the
rest of us
what can i do now that they're here i
have to take care of them
which by the way sends a signal to the
entire planet
joe biden wants you to come to america
why don't you go
now and that's why you see as i think
kevin mccarthy
pointed out when they were down on the
border you're seeing turks
you're seeing arabs you're seeing
chinese
people from over excuse me
people from all over the planet are
coming to the united states
and they're saying joe biden wants me to
come here they make t-shirts
that say biden wants me to come here uh
it can't be clearer what's happening
imagine donald trump putting kids in in
cargo shipping containers
and bringing the cages back and giving
them tinfoil blankets
i think it would be a different reaction
mr speaker as always thank you for being
with us